occupi la fatica ma fatica perché fanno
un gravi del braccio e quindi
chiaramente siamo davanti c'era lei
dietro così con l'estratto ciao ragazzi
sono qui insieme a due dei miei tre
fratelli loro fanno gli stuntman e ho
deciso di fargli vedere il mio video nel
quale proprio la zero la gravità zero
giusto nella gravità zero e meteorina ma
penso che morali neo inquilino del
passato perché quello che questa
mandando a particolari si ok ho capito e
questa cosa mi fa molto volare in
generale ma dove stiamo andando vi si
prova
inizia ad avere una leggerissima essi
missy ma ansia una piccola però
mamma se come suggerisce la porta io
finirò nelle turbine volevo dirti che ti
ho voluto bene
fateci delle salsicce con me per ogni
volta che esco da rete ma scusa non c'è
un modo per metterci la mia faccia
addosso uno di quelli
[Musica]
in realtà solo io ok dai aspetta che la
metto ora mettere quelle tute una figata
pazzesca perché ti senti un sacco nyon
genesis evangelion di spina la barba
traducano ma da se vestirà benzinai a sé
proprio come andava alla morte rallenta
il passo non solo caramelle a tappi per
le orecchie che giocai la fighissimo
bari un panda presolana c'è guarda
guarda un mezzo proprio dalla gabbia io
pensavo di aver fatto tipo e poi c'è lei
lei è per metà francese per metà con
adam ha sempre vissuto in francia
la cosa interessante è che le ha fatto
da bambino un sacco di danza classica
quindi per lei questo qui è un po come
un nuovo campolo il quale esplorare la
propria creatività delle ha iniziato a
volare due anni fa nel 2015 ha mollato
il suo lavoro meno di un mese fa ed è
venuta in italia per iniziare con anno
gravity a insegnare effettivamente
questo sport brava botta si vergognano
[Musica]
io mi sono buttato attaccato lavoro
eccolo resta il mio secondo innamorati
lasciano da solo no sembra che ti stile
tutti stia divertendo a ginocchio visto
che il ginocchio
vedi consenta di tutti quanti a questo
punto chi ti visita a baldini può vedere
il fenomeno da baraccone che stavi
l'argento anziché preso la rete sarebbe
stato bello se avessi preso il vetro ed
ore di basket come dice basta smettila
bassa marco io ho capito perché lei si è
girato ha detto oggi che non sai che le
cose che lei che hai fatto di solito si
fanno dopo molto tempo si è imparato un
attimo quel boss
capita per mira i 30 c piacerebbe che
diventassimo re dei nostri dei nostri
cosa uno del film specificato c'è il
cimitero la tua troppo accesa la
prossima volta iniziamo già vedere di
spiegare che frigo grazie a grazia dopo
l'attesa di nuovo a questo come può
combattere solo adesso ma c'è una grande
sì
quando in poi indossero solamente quella
tuta posso dirti che comunque non è che
si è andato male no una volta molto bene
ho visto che trovarla ni si vuol dire
traslativo vuol dire muoversi
lateralmente nella parte alla psiche
transazioni si si non so se le facevi
coscientemente no
credo che possiate mi amano questo
viaggio contro la gravità e anche contro
il tempo perché foto è tutto così
ritorno al futuro quello che stiamo
facendo è finito finalmente sono in
compagnia dei miei fratelli non e in che
senso
cioè nel senso questo diciamo che è
giusto che ti sei messo a fare ora
queste cose ci portiamo noi
ora grazie morte di 3 milioni ed è
proprio per culo come lagnese ragazzi
facciamo una rimonta senti se volete che
guglielmo si faccia veramente il culo
perché fa i video è certamente lotta per
noi la finale facciamo trovare lo
facciamo ritrovare affini macro
come sei laminazione non fosse già
abbastanza peccato il big three pronto
no assolutamente no guarda il terrore è
lesto naturalmente di politica no no io
sì qui mi diverto un sacco se mi vuoi
che lasciamo l'ha detto ma togliamo che
così bene gli spariamo a grettamente
semplice si sia richiesto di fare pure